I don't know what to say about my teacher, but my boyfriend,
Mizuhara-san, has done so much for me, and it's
cheap to meet him, so we share the same apartment and university.I
like the fact that I feel like it's fate.Well, he
has an average face, but I do
n't
think he's a nice person.In
the beginning.  I couldn't rely on her, but I
think she's a kind and honest person at heart.I'm
grateful for the movie,
too.But that's just because she's an actress.It's different from that of a man or a woman.
[Music]
Love is something completely different, isn't it?
This seems to be enough.If I want to take pictures, I
prefer bright places.My
master likes Ms. Mizuhara.So
maybe he likes her as a person.My
master likes Ms. Mizuhara as a woman.That's
not true.I
heard it once.  When I asked her if she liked me, she
said it would be a different topic. She said that she
clearly didn't like me. The
situation had changed since then, and there was no way she could
say that she liked me without being bothered by Daichi Mizuhara.
But the relationship is just an agreement, so
now it's an extension.I'm not stupid enough to get serious about her.Does
Mizuhara seriously think that?
Do you really think that everything can be split?I'll
pay her and go on a date again.  In the end, if everyone is satisfied with that,
do you really think that not a single person would want to be your real boyfriend?Human beings
aren't that easy.If you ask a beautiful woman like Mizuhara to go on a date with you, even if it's just for a few hours, you'll be like
this.  I wish the child was really my girlfriend, but that's what I think.That's
human.That's
not stupid at all.Among the customers,
there's someone who will make Mizuhara-san happy forever.This person will make me happy forever.
Have you ever thought that someone might be able to help you?